[Music]  Parliament sets out as red lights for  future relations with the UK while  Portugal's Prime Minister Antonio Costa  will debate the future of the European  Union with MEP s a reform of the EU  long-term budget framework and own  resources is on the agenda they want to  make sure that the EU can finance key  priorities and meet future challenges  Emmie Pease discuss an EU response to  u.s. President Donald Trump's threat to  impose tariffs on steel and aluminium  imports MEP s will debate crest freedom  and the safety of journalists after the  murder of Slovak journalist yang kucik  in February Parliament is sending a  delegation to Slovakia on a fact-finding  mission  [Music]  members of parliament will vote on a  major reform of the EU corporate tax  system the initiative would make  multinational companies pay taxes where  they make profits across the single  market